welcome to this video from round nine
coverage of the world championship match
and although this is no big
accomplishment after game eight I can
promise you that this game is more
exciting than the mentioned game eight
alright let's um start around two points
down and four games still to play so he
needs a win badly and finally he's
starting with 1d form and I'm really
glad to be honest if three you would
have seen another Berlin I probably
wouldn't have even watched the coverage
so on we have one deform and causal
place the news oh no surprise one of his
principal weapons against Wandy form and
unlock goes 44 f 3 this is no surprise
really and he has played this line quite
a number of times before he has played
in the World Championship match against
chronic inborn 2008 and also
successfully against him one how the
Chinese Grand Master wave on a very nice
game I think this was 2012 or 2011 I'm
not one hundred percent sure so this is
one of the lines that Magnus and his
team could expect in case of default
being played to have this this line okay
you played d5 relatively quickly a 3d
five Sol's of the main line a 3k
captured and c5 yeah this is the
absolute main line of this opening a lot
no took on d5 and here cards already
took a couple of minutes and not like 20
minutes but now some time and recaptured
with the poor now we see that I see
captions this year's four minutes this
is probably about right the times are
quite accurate that that you see him
okay e takes d5 and this really is a
surprise on the absolute top GM level
this move is almost forgotten it's a
very usual very normal to take with the
knight on d5 leading to a somewhat less
static position on gather night
immediately attacks here and whites
normal continuation is d take c5 in this
position which looks a bit a bit odd it
completely wrecks the Queen side but you
get two bishops and you have a for
coming this is just the beginning of
lots of theoretical or many theoretical
on variations but causal takes on d5
with the e porn and this is this whole
structure this structure white pawns
like this and black pawns like this this
is really out of fashion for like almost
almost a century al-qaeda's and server
if liberal calculation let's say since
nineteen thirty-eight the famous game
what winning against kappa blanca by but
Winnick one very nicely against the
former world champions or former world
champion against future world champion
and this is an absolute monster
classical game with the later Bishop e3
and this is again I didn't cover on
video yet but this you can cut just
Google this game but winning kappa
blanca 1938 you will get video analysis
on that and until or since that game the
structure is a little bit of cloud but
it seems that there are some new ideas
and counts
no um yeah goes his own way in openings
and he's got something interesting
prepared he played c4 and this move from
is of course yeah preventing Bishop d3
and at first it looks strange because it
gives up the pressure on deform but it
has some points I mean it establishes
oops this I didn't want to do actually
it establishes you three against two
pawns situation where black in the very
long run can get a passer and yeah it
prevents Bishop d3 still it looks like a
move that I think maybe let's say 15-20
years ago most people would have
condemned outright and I must admit if
someone would play this let's say in a
blitz game against me that I'm doing
live comments upon that I would probably
say this is a bad move because it's it
doesn't really ya fit well with my
strategical idea about chess because it
seems that you form at one point will
get white something in the center and it
doesn't look right to me but nowadays
some you you give those kind of
positions to computer and it tells you
it's equal and if you continue to
analyze with the computer it pretty much
quite often stays equal and this is
maybe just the case with this kind of
position it's maybe in traditional sense
it looks strange but in concrete terms
it's may be playable um yeah it's a
continued nitey 296 and now g4 very
energetic g4 is but but so typical white
wants to get this nice post on g3 for
the night he wants to play g5 pushing
away they have 69 and then general gain
space it also makes sure that black is
not
able to play the bishop out this in fact
has been played in a game Kasparov
against the judit polgár in the 90s and
Kasparov won a very nice quick game but
we see that Carlton improves upon that
he canceled Bishop g2 yeah the bishop on
g2 it looks at this pawn okay but it
helps to support reform so g2 is a
decent spot for the bishop and now
Knight a5 yeah the night is aiming for
be three in order to at one point just
capture the bishop get the bishop pair
back so that you don't have to fight
against that as well and it's also on
making sure that the potential attacking
piece is traded we will see this idea
later castles night b3 and rook a to
note that rook a2 is the more
interesting move compared to rook be one
rupee one is not directly bad but look H
who always has this idea to get the rook
over on the second rank and let it join
the attack easily so good move and now
be five black absolutely must get on
with counter plane because white is
quick on the kingside 9305 just wasting
no time it's quite funny that the
computer still also likes other words
like rook e8 orbit should be seven those
kind of move actually has been played I
was very surprised to see that this
position has been featured in an
endowment chess we should be seven
Andrew create both have been played
before only in one relatively low
profile game but still um yeah comes
with a 5 I think it's just better it
it's quicker with preparing before and
it introduces Luke
idea into the game where the rook might
help to defend on the 6th rank and ok a
white no White's turn he has two main
ideas basically g5 this is what he
played and there's also a form which I
think it's interesting after the capture
what can play Bishop g5 and this is I
think quite an interesting idea to get
this pin build-up now black could try to
return the porn like that and here just
done let's say Bishop d7 it's a really
murky position very hard to evaluate
note that this night is still on the
board it's never managed to capture the
bishop on c1 and it's not so clear what
this night is actually doing it could be
a good piece could be a bad piece this
wasn't interesting alternative a g5
playback on that he also played this why
it took some time thought you played
this more quickly but then it is just
all so very sensible looking moons night
back to e8 yeah the night wants to go
here and not to d7 blocking the bishop
and also the night here what also has
this additional possibility it's not
really working at the moment but in
general the night is not looking good
them so 98 is mentioned and now he for
this was of course the idea push g5 for
us to increase control and then play a
form and he is very interesting very
interesting moment he accounts took on
c1 which is a very human decision yeah
why human the things the computer really
prefers to play a night c7 year after
which white can play Bishop e3 end by
human logic this should favor white now
you keep the
two bishops you have a potential
additional attacking piece and it's not
so clear what this night is actually
doing now on b3 but still the computer
prefers this position to taking on on c1
which is really weird okay I couldn't
simply don't have the time to put in
hours to analyze wipe the computer gives
this evaluation but it's still tricky
night see one seems very human to me so
Queen takes and look a six it's all very
very logical helping in defense and
preparing before four there are two play
before you need of course the look
protected it wasn't protected on ahead
yeah and fishing now played five this is
also logical pretty much a case of what
else you need to spearhead pawn control
those squares and then push next DF porn
so white oops no them white has got four
points against three and therefore will
we roll his pawns up and black as
discount to play so we have a really
sharp battle now and this is exactly the
position that are not needed to to get
the chance to score his first win and to
make a match out of it really these two
points down but if he would win this
game I think the matches again
completely open still okay Carson has
the lead and so on but still this would
be a huge turnaround and I was getting
really excited too yeah to to have such
a fight okay e5 and 97 plate yeah the
son intends to have this possible
recapture with the night on a six black
also could have considered to play be
for this is actually what I was thinking
while watching the game because I
thought well let's get ahead as soon as
possible with your counter play
and then it seems to be a playable move
at least white can take and should take
not much else and now white also should
exchange it doesn't make much sense to
keep the rooks on the board move like
that it's a it's giving black too much
play you can compare this to to the game
somewhat later and see that black is a
couple of Tempe are so again let's check
before something like this is probably
what why should play and now on black
can initiate counterclaim against those
two week pawns and this can be supported
ideally with night to e6 it's a very
very complicated position that you can
devote lots of time on I would probably
assess this is about equal but not equal
in the sense of game eight where
everything was traded and basically yeah
not much was happening this is probably
a game with mutual chances that could go
either way so very interesting
alternative for black here to play I
actually prefer that a bit to the game
began the game looked very risky to me
but it seems that it was ok he played 97
as mentioned therefore basically
delaying the before breakthrough for one
we see what happens f4 logical you need
to push the pause and now before now you
really need to go ahead and now we see
after the capture oops after the capture
Anna took on a six and rook and light a
six so the night is actually protecting
the important before pong this moves
again is not good because of b3 the bond
is very strong we will see that in the
game as well
but compared to the game we have looks
on the board okay but the night is on c7
already and can help defending in the
game whiter skin to some time we we see
that after takes Knight takes and f5 the
night later needed to return anyway so
it was good to take on a six and
displace the snideness was perfectly all
right here in factor is a very important
moment if you look at the time spent on
pants i played this relatively quickly
he however also could have taken on b
form and this is in fact an interesting
alternative it at first it looks a bit
strange because it gives up the base of
the pawn chain and activates the night
looks a bit wrong but it's it's not so
clear at all this position is for
instance after f5 is really interesting
let's say knight c6 Queen f4 Queen B 6
and 92 and it feels completely unclear
to me black has the pawn of course but
white also has this attacking potential
and weak pawn on d5 to attack that this
is a quite interesting see takes before
was was ok i think but islands move of
course was not bad he played at five and
carson when they had pushed be three
after quite some some thought and at
exactly this position we have a
situation where cars almost down to
around thirty five minutes and anand
still had almost 70 minutes on his clock
double the time
plus he's got those nice advanced pawns
that almost guarantee some sort of the
tech so you could really at this moment
speculative Anand is able to to manage
to score his first full point and really
a yeah open up entirely new
possibilities for this match and here he
took ages really ages of time look at
that 21 minutes left so we spent almost
45 minutes on Queen f4 and after that he
played relatively quickly he had two
already worked out much of the things
that are happening now so what kind of
Defense should like now work out yeah
white mane attacking idea is to play f
6m trying to get a situation where f6
this answered with g6 and then the queen
is going to give made on g7 this is the
very crude but effective attacking plan
the other idea could be to play night to
age 5 and use the night with with the
attack like Knight takes g7 this kind of
ideas so black desperately needs some
defensive piece on the on the King side
and this is why he played 97 I think
it's again a very human decision the
computer also suggests to play king h
eight you know a potential group g8 is
an idea after f6d so you can play group
GA to cover so also a possibility but
97's just a good logical move and
contemplate this relatively quickly and
now I have six yeah what what else just
just the logical just logical
continuation and car this response as g6
again the you
movement on the computer actually wants
to play G takes f6 and claims that
legacy in good shape you very m got very
typical case where a human has a hard
time to believe in that means or if you
calculate it there you have a hard time
to believe that this is this can be good
cars are also rejected this move but it
seems to be in fact playable one very
important point is that night h5 which
at first looks completely crushing
because something like this looks
terrible this isn't great at all after
King h8 Queen g5 there's the strong rock
g8 and this is quite funny white cannot
take here because the queen is gone so
um yeah if whenever I takes check then
black come here gets a position yeah
being an exchange down but you get this
I've give this very important porn and
this is completely winning for black
because of night b5 and takes c3 white
has no way to prevent that so I can
prevent that and also stop the be born
so this is winning for black actually
very important line that cards and
actually showed in the press conference
but I think he general didn't trust the
idea to open up something on the
kingside this is why he played g6 and
the thing is he had 30 minutes left and
4 415 moves they don't have any
increment so you need to speed up here
and try to get trust your instinct a bit
and he he did that with the closing or
keeping the position closed so Queenie
schwa of course heading for age six and
four g7 and now black has only one
player will move
and this is what he played 98 you need
to anticipate this this made making
threat you have no time for for other
actually something like this for example
to cover its answered by rock edge for
and this is a look fo and this is
already a first mate now because of the
Queen h7 threat yep something like that
check check very important meeting motif
you need to know quite nice this is why
look to our King um lacking edge eight
is not not playable what he did idea to
play with g8 night e six covering g7
actually fails to a later Bishop h3 and
the simple capture and then it's made so
also losing for black yeah this is the
only move and this shows the general
problem of black in this position he's
got those pieces yeah pretty much stuck
on the King side and you have only have
one source of counter play this is the
beer pong but this is a very strong
source of counter play so it's it's very
very delicate and very complicated sort
of balance that is on the board I think
yeah Queen h6 and of course with this
idea and this means that black only has
one play will move B to the absolutely
only move that you can play here
everything else is just too slow if you
play up let's say I that's a queen 85
there's rook f4 and it's it's gone no
defense so be to the only moves yeah and
here it's a
supercritical obviously the last couple
of must have been very logical but what
does what should white play now of
course the the general idea is very easy
to spot if you want to get the rook to
h4 like this and deliver checkmate but
how your how I actually going to to
accomplish that um the beep on always
threatens to queen so the big question
is can you play rook f4 or not and in
fact after not much thought unplayed
regret for this was what you already had
planned a couple of levels ago so he
allowed the queening of the porn however
it seems that if you look at the the
continuation in the game that white
could also consider other moves um one
of them is 92 this is probably not a
move that you consider too deeply if you
have calculated you care for but it's a
very interesting idea the idea is to
activate the night here put some
pressure on d5 and just play a bit more
in a bit more restrained fashion this
can lead to quite interesting cases of
equality here for example white
threatens to take and then deliver only
seven so there should be six must be
played and situation like this is quite
amazingly um equal again yeah intending
to increase the pressure here you still
have this important porn on f6 look at
seven Queen a three-night c7 and move
to look at the beep on this is just the
possible line to illustrate that 92 was
a viable alternative but this is not
really am so relevant for the course of
the game because we she played look at
four and allowed the queening and Carson
I didn't take long Yankee quit and he
played all this very quickly this is I
mean they are the only moves but it
takes some confidence to dash out
everything here basically instantly and
not double check and whatever so were
very very nicely done Quint both check
and now we come to the to the turning
point of the game really white has the
threat that's clear and he needs to do
something against the check so he only
has two conceivable moves really and
this is Bishop everyone all night
everyone and it seems that Bishop have
won in this position should leave too I
should lead to to a relatively equal
position this sounds funny I know but
yeah White is threatening rook edge for
and the maid so like has very limited
choice he's got an extra Queen on extra
Queen um and yeah you need to cool you
need to Queen actually to prevent the
checkmate this is the only possible way
to play quite funny white then take the
Queen something like this can can happen
and after Bishop f5 fact honored in the
press conference mentioned that he had
planned this move beforehand and at
first thought it would win but then he
recognized that this is saving for black
covering the important
important at the bottom porn this is in
fact a big difference to this for
example Queen d7 here there's no not g6
and this isn't hacked not to one hundred
percent clear because of the g6 thread
g3x Queen Queen takes and then group g3
and it's not such a such a big issue
because the other thing is just just
winning however I am I was took looking
at Bishop f1 let me put it on the board
again because this is the better booth
and this in fact should lead to 22 about
Niko opposition let's say here you
should f5 and you need to need to cover
here and now why it has an interesting
idea i can play g6 and after that of
course the main thread forces like to
take with the bishop and then look g5
yeah this is quite interesting um black
has got three pieces that cannot move
it's a pin how the king also cannot move
so I'm black as in in sky trouble of
moving and okay you can try to just mix
the Queen and hope that nothing bad is
happening the other idea is to just sec
the night is probably the easiest move
just to do that group takes and then
that's a queen f3 to get c3 and I think
this should be at the end about equal
whites king is really open so on very
likely that there's some kind of
Perpetual check coming up yeah but in
the game but she didn't play Bishop f1
he played tonight everyone in let's say
six seconds he played this really
quickly and okay it threatens rue cage
for but cards and only
a very short time about one minute and
he was visibly excited and not like he
was jumping on his chair but usually
it's like he's like I'm just falling
which looks like he's falling asleep or
something not much expression and
Queenie one made him really exciting you
can see excited you can see that and the
reason is this queen is covering the
important age four square so that after
Luke age form like and simply sec the
queen that you just got and therefore
completely stops the attack so um look
edge for is never possible you also
cannot move the night and what can you
move basically nothing so uh not simply
blundered with nine f1 now black has an
extra queen for no compensation at all
and therefore honored here resigned and
this means that the matches almost over
almost over after nine games causal is
leading 6 2 3 and there's only one draw
that that he needs from three from the
three remaining games and I'm pretty
sure we will see a draw tomorrow to make
magnus carlsen that it's no need to
calculate the 16th world champion of
chess yeah what a turn of events here at
the end of the game I was really excited
hoping that she can maybe make just just
the fight out of it i'm not really i'm
taking side phul for any player but it
always exciting to see a closer closer
battle but yeah you you simply cannot
afford to play a move like night f1 and
give away the game he simply didn't show
up in the best possible shape I mean it
is always so hard to tell why is some
person playing below is his abilities
and so on very difficult to tell you
don't really know the the details what
what what's happening and you can only
speculate about about things and but
what I'm absolutely sure of is that
counsel is playing an excellent match in
terms of especially in terms of avoiding
mistakes look at this game again this is
he played this is not a long game emits
28 moves but he played without any
mistake there's no mistake absolutely no
you can you can suggest alternatives but
there's absolutely no clear improvement
anywhere it's a it's just a just
excellent play and okay Alan's night f1
is just a massive blunder that he
usually would not do but he's by now
probably completely unsettled by the
turn of this match though I must say
that he looked really confident during
the game you can notice with the webcam
and so on you you will see how the
players look like he looked really
confident actually and what I also think
i'm thinking it's it's it's hard to hard
to tell but after the game after this
she resigned and congratulated magnets
on the victory they did some brief
analysis on the board and this she was
far more i think yeah relax this the
wrong word but he he was really upset
after game 6 in the press conference and
so on but today I always almost had the
feeling that did it felt like him some
weight was put off his shoulders I don't
know he didn't it didn't seem very very
angry to me or anything probably and
just um yeah accepting what is basically
unavoidable
at the end and yeah it's always it's
always funny to to look at and quotes
that people make about the world
champions of chess and the world
championship and won funny funny thing
that that I once read is I'm not quite
sure who some of the world champions
some world champion said that i'm not
sure if it was tongue or Spassky one of
those older world champions they they
said that being the chess world champion
is nice but being the former chess world
champion is far nicer because you always
welcome people like to have you around
you're not really a threat to any one's
ambitions anymore but you're just the
elder statesman and i appreciate it for
your experience what you've done and so
on and you don't really need the stress
and hardship off of any competition
anymore and yeah maybe being an ex-world
champion can um can even be good for our
wishes chest you you never know maybe
it's still continuing to play and try to
try to do something you you never know
for chronic for example it was for his
chest it was excellent 22 to see him
lose the title in 2008 he's after that
2009-10 and follow me yes here you
really again sharpened up his play and I
think really improved even and nowadays
is still am a massive contender for the
title and okay we're getting a bit of
ahead of ourselves because theoretically
speaking Carlton has not yet won the
match and I think he's really aware of
that he needs to make those make this
one draw and I'm not saying that he will
get into trouble doing that but it's
still something you need to do if you if
you place there tomorrow and no blunder
sapana in a couple of moves then the non
and will win the game and then it's yeah
it's it's the continuing so okay let's
see if the 22nd of November tomorrow
will we see a new world champion or
we'll need to wait a couple of days um
yeah I hope you enjoyed this coverage a
bit of a disappointing end to this to
this game but it shows that um yeah we
have a clear difference in this match in
terms of yeah just um yeah we like well
no no i don't i like the english word
you're just the sort of you're not
making many mistakes it's just very
cards can really much rely on his
calculating abilities and just plain
without any any major glitches and this
is simply what on earth is not managing
yeah thanks for watching and i'll be
covering the next and probably final
game tomorrow as well thanks for
watching